I want everyone in this room to pull out
their phones do not take it off airplane
mode do not take it off take it off
already
do not okay because they mess up the
audio for you guys okay
now go to your settings settings click
on cellular you're gonna have to help
Steve porno came on design almost well
you're doing it wrong all right now
scroll until you see already clicking
them so you there okay go to your go to
your point AB app mm-hmm scroll until
you see something called uninstalled
apps what is this oh I see it eight
point eight megabytes that's not bad
804 megabyte that's bad Oh seventy three
point eight mega 73 yeah 73 point I have
Co V 19 what does it mean 70 million
terabytes she's seen it come on no one's
gonna see me she's see me mate it's
actually probably a surprise for me what
do I neither do did you see it yeah but
what does it do is it miss 1.3 gigs
1.3 gigs yeah oh [ __ ] that's a lie day
1.3 okay so the three of you guys are
like oh yeah gigs not megabytes I have
six hundred and twenty megabytes oh [ __ ]
I have 50 megabytes I just have 8.8 what
do I have so many high Q so what do I do
well I mean we have a lot - what does it
mean this is what it means
I tell me Nikki's ass is so [ __ ] big
that's taking up a bunch of [ __ ] space
well not for you yeah why'd you
uninstall it then so the new updates
even as far back as the iOS 13 because
right now everyone's on 14 I believe yes
now you're gonna go to your no you're
gonna click on your name is this his mom
[ __ ] TIFF general go to general go to go
to what go to general and then go to
about and then you're gonna see supper
bored [ __ ] who have googled what about
the guys have had Google phones thirteen
point three one thirty two point three
one yeah thirteen thirty-one so they're
saying is this a scam listen and anyone
who has iOS a thirteen thirteen are
experiencing this bug that this bug is
eating up a [ __ ] ton of data and there's
people that have had to contact their
carrier services because they don't have
like the unlimited so they have to add
more data so they don't go over and like
it's [ __ ] everyone up so keep a
lookout on your data
apparently Apple knows what's going on
but they haven't as of right now they
have not released a new update to fix
the bug [ __ ] ton of data is being eaten
up by this [ __ ] uninstalled my date
is so [ __ ] right now how do i clean
this show you ha a shower and then i
scrub it clean with the one in the
french maid oh but yeah so god damn it i
got high all right so this is gonna be
talking about Niki's ass don't look at
my boy
do you want that in a black song yeah
okay yeah so we don't know yet that's
the thing we don't know how to fix this
[ __ ] it's message back to Android
that's what I'm actually what they're
reporting they're like Apple just gave
everyone a reason to quit
yeah I agree man Android rocks except I
can't get my [ __ ] photos so like all
these pictures I have Nikki's ass I'm a
console how do I get them on my new
phone I can't
your little you love your Apple watch
now we're talking about you love your
Apple watch no but I but I like it but
it's fine but I'm talking about my photo
collection though bad you could get
these s on your watch to you can
actually I want the timer's a he's like
boring a picture her tap [ __ ] sug
lame please so boring though Google yeah
I never don't are you late I'm like Siri
hello
see I'm seeing your other robot's name
in bed no and then so our trash cans
voice acting on God and then we like oh
okay did you really
we got it for free okay why can't you
just can't talk though is he like I'm
full help me I'm full
that's my free it was a gift
uh-huh chill anyway what's the advantage
of a talking trash really don't so you
have to touch it and then you go open
can and then it opens and so it also has
a sensor though for when you don't want
to speak to it so you just wave over it
and then it opens but the new house the
weight like the exact place where we
left the trashcan and we walked by that
area a lot and it opens all the time so
I covered the sensor now we have to keep
the stupid I cannot I really could not
like she yeah she's bitching about how I
know but it doesn't understand Spanish
oh and then you're like hey Google open
the [ __ ] trash can spread of your Co
beam I'm not loving that yet that it's
like a oh okay so we're back to this
thing so a TMC and Verizon have said
that they're they have told their users
that they're seeing data consumption
associated with this bug on their
network as well but it doesn't seem like
they're really doing anything about it
so we're all kind of [ __ ] as of right
now I don't they're not - only 8.8
[Laughter]
but yeah so I know pictures it's a you
have pictures just when you're making me
school I was like it's just how many
photos I have it says $20,000 yeah I
have 745 yeah I just got this [ __ ]
phone so you guys know how much where do
you go what do you think it was under
general when you made me scroll when you
look through the software version it
shows how many songs videos photos 1108
oh I have twenty thousand two hundred
and ninety one okay I don't know about
then twenty thousand one because I have
photos from back in twenty fourteen
fifty i've photos from 2011 in tech yeah
i have seventeen thousand four thousand
do it you guys are [ __ ] really
addicted to your phones that [ __ ] so sad
oh so sad
capturing memories all the time oh my
god no yeah I got a bunch of [ __ ] like
this that's tepid Nick that's all they
came over my phone I was like okay I'm
like you can see down here - no she's
right though you could technically see
an ass shot if it was down here with not
dude no it's cuz they they took so many
goddamn pictures on my phone that day
because Nick is low on battery yeah
worried about you Delita
I mean how do you do that oh no no it's
easy that's so tight and then I didn't
know that we all of that Wow okay cool
so how's your chariot right
but if you don't want to do it you just
put cancel okay well I don't want to do
it bill only because I don't know
exactly which ones I would like to get
rid of the waste though but I do like
pictures of you and Nicki with Tom
Holland while he's acts like he does
know who the [ __ ] well he doesn't know
who the [ __ ] you are it's an inside joke
me and Tom I gotta say buddy he knew
that you guys were there but he refused
to even look at you because did you see
a viral video of him when you told to
paparazzi please stop yelling at me he
looked like he was having that was
during why you guys were there it was
right like we were really hot so I was
like intimidating to look I and I get it
like weeks all right through so those
who you don't know maybe we'll find the
video maybe you want I'll try to send to
you right we did it
but yeah funny cuz Nikki and and TIFF
are on the same red carpet as Tom
Hollands again Chris Pratt and Chris
Pratt
yeah and like you guys look like you
guys look like here on the same movie
together but you guys are all are just
promoting the movie and he's like
theatre with them and Isaac when you
watched it with Chris Pratt I breathed
in some of Chris Pratt's yeah and
Octavia is a very own video patron no
okay you were about to go in know what
if it was a patron I was gonna talk
about the movies box office but now I
want yeah we like them it's cuz of
Coleman it's not the movies taught the
movie was fantastic yeah deep cried oh
they're doing the right thing with Mulan
they're doing the
with [ __ ] James Bond you know how like
the whole like everyone China and then
like the worst time I yeah but I got
safe not not even kidding this movie
onward is [ __ ] dope it's actually
really good I was surprised it was so
cute look cuz I didn't know what they
were going for cuz I'm like blue people
why are they blue this now is terrible I
didn't know no but I didn't know why
they're blue right
you're never gonna Smurfs but it's cuz
they're elves no elves that's another
elves [ __ ] Smurfs [ __ ] you don't
want a [ __ ] dark Elvis a smart girl
dark elf dumb [ __ ] Smurf you're dumb
as [ __ ] no but they're dark elves dumb
[ __ ] so that's why they're not high
elves high elves are very well I need
dark elves are blue you just learned
about this oh yeah I know I just know
people call you Dwight Schrute
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]